Lisa mihalick yeah that's her name she's
been on this channel before and never
have we ever gonna try not to laugh
together and we never played never have
I ever either and still now parties we
failed the challenge I'm laughing in the
video I will have a hard time not laugh
laugh you can check out her YouTube
channel she's also one of the stars of
ice the movie which is now available on
Vimeo it's gonna be on Amazon soon you
could go purchase it yourself and
meantime check out her channel Lisa
two rules here what are the rules one
you try not to laugh okay that's already
gonna be - try not to smile you got to
contain it cuz you could easily hold
back a laugh a smile can be harder can
you breathe I can occasionally say
something you can blink okay pick your
nose you can floss your teeth but you
cannot smile or laugh get it out of your
system
I'm gonna punch you in your face I'll
punch you in the face Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's an alligator there wait Watson
ouch
hurt her wait why is anything anyone
will laugh at the world is sick Lisa
yeah it's only game goodbye in our video
[Music]
oh really
[Music]
I'm oh oh that was oh that's creepy
already I'm laughing because you're
laughing or he was Captain America will
not begin the push-up section ready
begin down
[Music]
China China China China China China that
was so weird
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like sad and then it's funny
[Music]
oh no doesn't expire yeah did you've a
wildebeest getting killed by live so I
used computers to turn the wildebeest
into a Nancy Oh Devon glad that it's
dead
oh my gosh I don't know how to react to
this I mean what is real to catch a
predator today here to tell us what
you're doing here sorry
wait what I don't understand this
is this a real episode of To Catch a
Predator what if you got away is that it
that's the end already
you know every try not to laugh has some
stuff where you go why are people
laughing at this America's Funniest Home
Videos where it's like some of them I'm
like this looks like it really hurts
wire yeah well you're laughing you're
sensitive like that I feel like Trump is
a easy thing to make funny the one that
I thought we were just not in sync but
also I'm trying to keep serious because
it's a challenge reminding myself of
what could be sad yeah you really want
to win the Tigers Wow my girlfriend's
really like into nature documentaries
and stuff so she'll watch a lot of stuff
about animals and I'll see like footage
like this I'm always like oh wow that's
really sad but it's part of life and I
always feel sad for the animal being
hunted
I don't even know that's so people think
like oh let's make this not sad let's
Photoshop completely not work for me it
worked for that if they could do that
for every nature documentary that would
be great yeah that's what it comes to I
think this is a real To Catch a Predator
episode was it I don't even know where
the guy just successfully got away
because they were too slow with the bear
head there was just part of what to make
it funny
Oh cuz he was like oh oh right let me
teach you how Comedy Works when we're
done all the time and then I have to
watch comedy nothing's nothing's funny
that's the problem you just don't get it
well at least I think you successfully
pass a transfer laughs oh I'll admit
I've had harder challenges but this was
not too bad Ferguson sometimes I watch
them and they're just not funny at all
this one had some ones that if I did not
have to laugh I would have been laughing
oh well you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
better get notified every time one of
our bids is up Lisa mahalik is has her
own YouTube channel and Lisa my cowlick
also has ice the movie out on Vimeo
right now on Amazon thanks for being
here Lisa mr. no-name
and no Marie
[Laughter]